[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
previously on model lifestyle
[Music]
yeah Wow
they're scared very easily he's not
moving buddy whoa this guy is closer
than I thought it would be
[Music]
these are foxes look at this Wow hey
check it out check it out
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
hey guys I'm going for a hike here in
South Korea with Tim and Daisy some of
my older friends here that I've met here
previous time Tim husband a model of the
agency that I'm with here and he's with
Daisy and they say open her own agency
here in South Korea and we're gonna go
and have a cool nice Pike let's go
all right I'm supposed to meet them
somewhere so we're gonna walk there but
I don't want to take too long so let's
just teleport
okay we're at census station here in
Seoul I'm supposed to meet them at an
exit number eight so let's see
[Music]
here
yeah how are you
so this is ten man this is Daisy
that is the mountain we're going to
climb
[Music]
almost no city we're gone already so
cool that was a minute
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so Tim just said this is like a king's
tomb or something we don't know all the
facts but he's like I got away all the
trees here so you can have a look over
his kingdom
according to Shinto is in the religion
that's for all of prevalent in Japan but
also Korea they live in the spirits of
the forest so it's natural to bury their
leaders somewhere we've been where these
periods we protect them so that's why
they're buried right here because the
spreads of the forest all right so this
is like a prayer thing to their gods out
here in the forest nope come something
uh I'm gonna say oh my Korean is
terrible all right you have to choose
boring fine why I guess oh my goodness
[Music]
there's no animals really on this kind
of pillow right a monk once really yeah
monkeys and that kind of stuff not
really think I saw gecko I saw a gecko
at the other place huh
no no the absolute has nothing else it's
training Noel dynamos in Korea anymore
Timmy's from Canada you guys didn't know
that
that's why hide it in there Tim
[Music]
sometimes you just get tired of the city
and this is like he's in the city but
outside the city it's like so it's quick
to get here there's a cargo we're unique
over there and then you can see jump
ship our the 100 yeah they're number
sent our guys the bronze building that
you drive by sometime oh yeah that one
Oh
[Music]
look is this
[Music]
Wow very small war bunker oh my goodness
[Music]
[Applause]
Wow alright guys see this I mean a war
bunker Wow
my goodness
very short if I have to stand up let's
get out of here
[Music]
this is a lot of fun
[Music]
oh here we are at the top off the
mountain that is the Korean flag hanging
here above Seoul South Korea are you
guys tired
nah
[Music]
look what days is this it's crazy look
at that look how dangerous that is oh my
goodness don't move too much you're
gonna fall no thank you I think I'll
stay up here we're safe what is that hmm
put your finger put your finger close
they don't have any perspectives how
bigoted so we were over there just a few
minutes ago and now we're right here
we're almost finished here of the trip
look at this beautiful view how's the
cool thing about modeling you travel to
all these countries and see all these
amazing places different cultures people
and views like this hey buddy look at
that see it there he goes yeah it's a
nice temple over here check it out let's
have a look at this
do you guys know what that means oh it's
not Korean Chinese alright alright so
let's take our shoes off
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
okay what's huge for this one I don't
know what is it for Billy's photo they
had a key for girl yeah it's for the
what people and bad people for the dead
people yes huh would be this this one so
how old is this temple what in years ago
but many time it's this building was a
fighter because of work I was in
destroyed with the war okay thank you
thank you
I mean nice people across the world
there's a lot of cool and interesting
things I mean look at this thing like a
dragon kind of thing
this is another part of the temple there
is Tim as well Wow alright so this is
big statue of Buddha is it yeah let's
have a closer look
so they just explained a long time ago
the Korean people used to write in
Chinese so that is Chinese writing
actually not Korean
[Music]
it's like gold
[Music]
Buddhists water so this is very clean
water from the monsoon baby yeah how
does it taste cold
[Music]
all right so what are you grateful this
second yeah like um ice noodles right so
this is very popular here in Korea so
I'm gonna try this out for the first
time its enemies busy with he's already
[Music]
something we are filming him
put a drop of mustard a little mustard
and then we got to add this happen
Pacific time with vinegar you can even
take a spoon and pour some on the spoon
I don't know but you don't look so sure
yeah Tim over here is enjoying it well
different it'll take a couple bites but
it's not bad
okay to get by again it's not bad it's
very cold the text is not bad it's not
too salty or anything is just like nice
and smooth and there's always made to
food and I saw at the Ganga
this is very good
[Music]
you